vous savez quand on ne bouge pas par
régine gal êtes au courant
bush et sèche le symbole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux faire une interview fin du monde
que vous êtes quelqu'un de spécial
mangue et comme on vient de le voir
faire une interview fin du monde
alors c'est la fin du monde michel oui
les cordeaux c'est la fin du monde si
vous deviez sauver un livre moi je
prendrais la bible ouais parce que bon
c'est pas abouti
mais on peut refaire plein à partir de
la bible donc c'est très générateur quoi
il ya plein de petites histoires on peut
saluer a beaucoup servi pour refaire des
livres à partir de si vous deviez sauver
un animal le bichon frisé le bichon
frisé oui vous aimez les bichons frisés
oui c'est magnifique votre grand mère
avait un bichon frisé
baisse et comme c'est un tout petit
chien c'est comme une peluche c'est
toujours le team n non ça boit pas
beaucoup mais pas du tout n'ont presque
pas et ça va nous sautent dessus ça vous
laisse en fait c'est hyper gentil
si vous deviez sauver une idée une idée
aussi je vais être un peu chiant c'est
peut-être les l'idée de la preuve
mathématique ouais ça c'est bien ça
beaucoup s'est écrié nous simplifie la
question suivante un disque et on a trop
le vôtre non non en béton avant le sait
mieux ouais un film peut-être murnau
l'aurore ouais si vous aviez sauver un
sexe social non
mais ça veut dire se pose même pas une
drogue ben moi je dirais le tabac ça
l'air de rien mais c'est bien si vous
deviez sauver un homme politique ce
serait qui
tuvéri tiberi 60
mois je sais pas j'ai rien contre ça
fait plaisir à monsieur mois deux mois
au bon honnêtement j'aime bien
chevènement mai
désolé désolé pour les plus futiles eu
un coup de pied comme le pigeon
non j'aime bien chevènement chevènement
ah ouais ouais je trouve qu'il est
courageux bas les jeunes bon dieu qui
l'a sauvé une fois il ya des écoutes est
bien possible écoutez bien on rallume
est ce que vous connaissez l'interview
fin du monde
ans
[Musique]
c'est la fin du monde mesdames messieurs
ça commence très clément
donc vous avez quand même le choix
michèle bernier ou pouvait sauver un
certain nombre de gens alors si vous
deviez sauver un écrivain
marc-edouard nabe pourquoi est-ce que je
n'ai jamais lu mais
mais je les adore avant j'aime ça j'aime
ce mec parce que je sais pas il est à
part et en plus je connais bien son papa
papa tu veux pas voilà j'aime bien mark
edwards très bien marquer normal qui
vient de publier aux rochers sont le
dernier tome de son journal voilà qui
revoit là j'aime bien si vous deviez
sauver un acteur
je peux en prendre deux ou alors allez
un américain denzel washington je trouve
sublime en sexy et et jean pierre bacri
pour m'énerver
avec lui ou c'est vrai oui
oui je pense à la fin du monde vous
imaginez qu'un des sols justement aura
et énervé donc encore plus énervé quoi
un chanteur
ça va faire un peu lèche bottes mais
richard cocciante je pense oui
faut dire c'est vachement bien
deux étrangers lui et moi 6 rue des
verres c'est génial cette vacance
le désir de rencontrer ce soir parfois
c'est un grand moment mais la haye à
gilles bernier va rencontrer richard
cocciante si vous deviez sauver un
animateur de télé
laurent cabrol laurent cabrol quoi
parce que je suis une femme du téléachat
oui
j'ai jamais rien y avait dix animateurs
de télé si vous deviez sauver un
animateur de télé qui s'habille toujours
en noir
c'est pas le mec qui fait j'aimerais
jour du seigneur ça
s'est perdu
si vous deviez sauver un membre du
public ici ce soir
[Musique]
là là je sais pas à qui peuvent porter
voilà allez voilà messi va les voiles et
là on est
d'accord la fin du monde alors stéphane
voilà
alors
si vous deviez serez un philosophe un
philosophe il y en a je suis pas ce
qu'est ce qui fait bien de dire en ce
moment chez pai bernard henri lévy vient
ce soir bah ça ferait de un peu ça fout
un coup richard cocciante ouais ça fait
2 qui viennent ou alors faut que ce soit
la fin du monde ce soir parce que
j'adorais ça risque d'être la famille
je vous demande de vous arrêter
un chat mon chien
un homme politique
assez dur ah oui ce calcul comment il
s'appelait celui que j'étais venu là que
j'aimais bien la musau amusé au premier
un dieu on va là est formidable allié
renault est le mieux nos malades hui ça
sympa lui passerait bien voit jamais
d'en bas il n'a pas été très
bien un cadreur
lui parce qu'il est à mes genoux est-ce
qu'on peut être qu'on peut filmer ce
cadre heures qui est sauvé par vous
appelez comment commencer votre petit
nom pas très bas trévois là c'est bien
quand on aura fait que sauver mais
rester au pied de michel mallet vous
aurez bien sûr un coût un peintre un
peintre monsieur goncalves il vient de
refaire toute ma
c'est bon ils s'appellent comme une
attention
que saluer
un
dictateur un démon fils
bravo bravo un
joueur de foot
je peux pas prendre l'équipe de france
ça ben alors l'équipe de fluxys de
france très bien barbeau michèle bernier
j'allais gagner
[Musique]
à
voilà ces mots chippendales âmes ou
wallace et voilà
bravo et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu